moi je travaille sur les glioblastomes
sont des cancers du cerveau très
agressive très invasif et je travaille
également en fait en prévention du
cancer et je travaille avec des baies et
les fleurs de sureau
donc on retrouve dans notre alimentation
et les bêtes se re contiennent beaucoup
d'enthousiaste in extremis pigment qui
donne la couleur bleu rouge aux fruits
sont connus pour être anti oxydants as
inflammatoires donc nous on s'est
demandé c'était quoi en gros les
propriétés chimiques préventive des
extraits d'un bébé et des fleurs sur des
lignées de cellules de glioblastome et
une lignée de cellules endothéliales qui
sont les vaisseaux sanguins et est-ce
qu'on a démontré jusqu'à présent c'est
que ça peut inhiber la prolifération des
cellules et que ça a affecté le sexy
muller et de manger ces petits fruits là
où boire l'épisode 2 de fleurs de sureau
peuvent aider à prévenir
la formation de tumeurs cancéreuses